yeah kristen chenoweth there doing her
thing it's good we're we're coming back
online now we have to talk about what's
going on here locally because the strip
is on fire too debbie gibson and joey
mcintyre teamed up for a mini residency
at the venetian well las vegas now had
the chance to talk to the singers about
how all this came about
you know i basically attribute all the
good ideas to joey um he
he initiated us doing lost in your eyes
on the mixtape tour
and then actually like you know about
almost two years later i was like you
know what the fans are demanding the
recording let's do it and joe was like
let's go one better and plan some live
shows in vegas you know it's like just
something to look forward to i said
let's let's put some shows together you
know so we can look forward to something
so our fans can look forward to
something
yes we are looking forward to it well
they have four shows left at the
venetian and there are a few tickets
left this was so popular they had to add
more shows i did so you can catch the
full interview with them
during las vegas now at three o'clock
this afternoon and that's right here of
course on channel